chant prénatal coach pour parents
réflexologie sophrologie telles étaient
les stands présents à l'occasion du
premier salon de la parentalité du
bien-être à trappes
il est organisé par à cali l'association
des créateurs de lien inter
générationnel en collaboration avec
saint quentin en yvelines
le parent parfait n'existe pas mais par
contre le parent est tous les jours
confronté à des questionnements des
doutes des difficultés des joies des
peines qui le confronte à ses propres
limites et du coup savoir qu'il peut
comme on dire être soutenu dans ses
actions au quotidien avec ses enfants et
bien
ça peut être très aidant pour lui encore
faut-il qu'ils sachent vers qui se
retourner d'où l'utilité de ce salon
pour nous faire connaître auprès buts
lors de ce salon d'hiver professionnels
de soutien à la parentalité du bien-être
sont présents pour répondre aux
difficultés et questions des parents
c'est plutôt vraiment revoir
qu'est-ce que dans le quai ce que moi je
fais qui a une incidence sur le
comportement de l'enfant est ce que je
suis pas en train d'empirer la situation
quand l'enfant vit des difficultés et
donc qu'est-ce que je peux faire - en
tant qu'adulte pour améliorer la
relation et surtout le comportement
finalement de l'enfant dans des ateliers
étaient organisés afin de permettre une
découverte concrète de certaines
techniques ou pratiques
l'idée c'est de rentrer en communication
avec son enfant déjà in utero j'ai
ensuite quand il est né et plus tard
quand il grandit en fait via la musique
et le toucher l'association à cali
espère pouvoir renouveler cette
expérience l'année prochaine avec un
deuxième salon